hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd
and skin care user we talk a lot about
how to use your products but today i
wanted to talk about how
not to use your products so i'm going to
go through some of the mistakes i see
people making when
using their products and why you
shouldn't do that
if you like talking nerdy about beauty
click the like the subscribe and the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos
first the dropper on the face i see this
a lot on social media and i guess it
looks really cool
but the issue is that droppers aren't
meant to be used that way
and what i mean by that is the
preservative system inside the product
isn't designed to let you use it that
way so preservatives are put into a
product to stop
microbes like bacteria and fungi from
growing too much
if you have too much bacteria and fungi
in there you can end up with really
nasty infections when you put that
product back on your face
the way that they test a preservative
system is by mixing the product with
fungi of bacteria
and then waiting and seeing how much
fungi and bacteria grow
a good preservative system will actually
decrease the amount of fungi and
bacteria will actually kill anything
that's been added
with a bad preservative system the
bacteria and fungi might just
not change or they might even be allowed
to grow
with challenge testing the fungi or
bacteria actually gets reintroduced so
part way through the testing they chuck
in a bit more so this is meant to
simulate what would happen
if you dug into a jar with a dirty
finger or you touched a wand to your
skin or lips and it wasn't completely
clean
if the product passes this challenge
testing that means that you can put it
in a riskier type of packaging so like a
jar
or a product that has an applicator wand
and in general products want to minimize
the amount of preservatives they use
they want to put in just enough to do
the job preservatives tend to be
irritating and allergenic if you have
too much
they are some of the more irritating and
allergenic ingredients that you find in
cosmetics
so if you're touching the dropper to
your face you're making the preservative
system
do something that it wasn't meant to do
it's not in its job description
the second mistake is saving up the
serum from your sheet masks
this is a similar issue again you're
making the preservative system do a job
that it wasn't meant to do
single-use foil sachets are considered
one of the safest types of packaging
they're meant to be single used there's
no expected shelf life
after you open it there's not even air
going into it like there is in a tube
where
you dispense them and then a little bit
of air gets sucked back in
the preservative systems for these tend
to be the weakest so if you're saving up
the extra source
and keeping it for a week or so then
again you're making it do a job that it
wasn't meant to do
it is possible that the preservative
system can stand up to this
but really that product was only ever
intended to be used a few hours after
opening not
a few days or a week or a month after
you've opened up the sachet of the air
then there are lots of micros in the air
and cosmetics are really good food for
microbes
it's watery there's lots of nutrients
for them to grow sheet masks are usually
at a nice skin friendly and
micro friendly ph you're also probably
keeping it at room temperature which is
warm enough for these microbes to
usually reproduce really quickly and so
you are risking contamination
again with the bacteria talk getting
moisture into your products
water is really good for microbial
growth if you have a cosmetic product
then generally you will need to have a
preservative if it's got water in it
if you want it to last for longer than
like a week if there's extra water going
into a product then this can lead to
trouble
the worst situation is if there's a
product that has a big opening like a
hair mask in a jar
that you take into the shower and water
literally drips into it
if you're adding extra water a lot of
the time this sits on top
and so this doesn't get enough
preservative that extra water will be a
really good place for bacteria and
microbes to start growing
even if you just start using a product
in a damp bathroom
after you showered there might be enough
moisture there to cause problems so for
example if you get condensation inside
the container
inside like the walls of a jar for
example then
bacteria and microbes can start growing
there so if you want to avoid this water
contamination if you go into the shower
then it's a good idea to scoop out the
product and put it into a little
container like
one of these caps that you get from a
whole bunch of different products
if you're putting on skincare in the
bathroom let your bathroom air out and
dry out a bit before you start doing
your skincare routine
or you can use them in a different room
maybe your bedroom instead
transferring your products into a
different container i've been guilty of
this one in the past
it can be okay but you have to be really
careful
firstly the container has to be very
clean the preservative system in the
product might not be designed to
deal with whatever dust or bits of
cardboard or whatever's inside the
container
some containers are also incompatible
with certain products
glass is generally okay but plastics can
react with preservatives
or active ingredients or different
solvents inside the product
sunscreen ingredients for example can
soak into plastics and so that means you
have less of the sunscreen ingredients
in your sunscreen
they can also just dissolve the
container so if you have
a really clean container if you're only
putting the product in there for a very
short amount of time
or if you know that that container was
designed for that purpose
then it can be okay you can also test
the container with the product so you
can smear it on and look for visible
changes
but sometimes the changes aren't that
obvious so
just keep that in mind when you're using
that product not
applying enough sunscreen i see a little
goes a long way
all the time in sunscreen reviews the
problem is sunscreen is like
paint you are trying to hide your skin
from the sun
sunscreen is tested at two milligrams
per square centimeter to get that spf
label on the bottle
you can apply less sunscreen but the spf
will generally go down linearly
so that means if you apply half the
amount then you get about half the spf
but you run into more issues if you
apply less than half the amount
so your skin isn't flat it's
microscopically bumpy there are lots of
hills and valleys
so when you apply the sunscreen you fill
in the valleys first and if you don't
have enough sunscreen then you might not
be covering the tops of the heels of
your skin enough
and i think a lot of people do run into
this issue because there are studies
showing that most people
apply less than half the required amount
now the amount that you need to apply
does depend on how big your face is
but a general rule that covers pretty
much everyone is a quarter teaspoon for
your face
not including your ears or neck mixing
sunscreen with other products
it's really tempting to mix a sunscreen
with other products before you put it on
some sunscreens have really bad white
casts so mixing it with say
foundation makes it look a bit less
white when you put it on
the texture of some sunscreens also just
isn't great and so that way you can
dilute the texture and make it a bit
more wearable
some of us are lazy and we just want to
have one step
the problem is when you mix the
sunscreen with something else
then it can interfere with the film
formation when a sunscreen is tested
it's tested on its own on bare skin
and it's really important that it forms
a continuous film so that the sunscreen
can be
spread out evenly so you get even
protection if you add other stuff in
there it can mess up the microscopic
structure of the sunscreen
sunscreens are emulsions they're a bit
like mayonnaise if you add too much oil
or too much vinegar or too much
lecithin or whatever you can actually
break that emulsion
the mayonnaise will separate and same
with sunscreens
if it separates then you're not getting
that even layer so you shouldn't be
mixing sunscreens with well
anything so this is things like
foundations pigment drops and oils
so if you want other products on your
face as well then
apply it in layers in general it's a
good idea to wait five to ten minutes
after you've put on your sunscreen to
put on extra layers like foundation
it's also a good idea to find a
sunscreen that already does what you
want
so if you want to avoid a white cast
then maybe look for a chemical sunscreen
if you only want to do one step then
maybe look for a tinted sunscreen that
isn't too tinted so you can still apply
the right amount
if you want a product that's more
moisturizing then look for a sunscreen
that already has moisturizing
ingredients on it
or look for a moisturizer with spf
leaving
sunscreen in the heat with sunscreens
it's important to have the filters
distributed evenly through the whole
product
it's a bit like paint the pigment needs
to be evenly distributed
if it's settled out then you're not
going to get even coverage it's the same
idea with sunscreens
sunscreen should be formulated so that
the filters are spread evenly in the
product throughout the whole shelf life
but it does depend on storage heat is
something that's really good at making
sunscreens separate
so if you go to the beach and you keep
the bottle in the sun
that's not good if you keep your
sunscreen in the car
you put it in the glove box and you
leave your car parked in the sun
that's also not good i know it seems
like a good idea to leave a bottle of
sunscreen in the car so you don't forget
it
but because of the heat this is usually
not a great idea
so a better idea would be to keep your
sunscreen in your handbag
where it tends to have cooler
temperatures if you're going to the
beach
cover up your sunscreen with something
that reflects light so maybe a white
towel
even better keep it in a cooler bag also
pay attention to the expiry date
if you're not very good at keeping your
sunscreen out of the heat then make sure
you buy a new one every summer
derma rolling over products that aren't
meant to be derma rolled over
so with a derma roller you're opening up
channels in your skin
to let skincare products go deeper and
if they're not meant to go deeper then
this can be bad
some derma rollers have shorter needles
and these don't go as deep into your
skin so they tend to be a bit safer
but most products are designed to sit on
the surface of your skin
your skin is a good barrier so a lot of
the time the products have a higher
concentration
so that the amount that gets through the
barrier is still effective
so you can think of it like a slow
release but if you've got these extra
channels in your skin from the needles
then it's like a shortcut it's like it
suddenly all gets released at once
it's a bit like if you have an icy drink
if you drink it slowly it's really nice
but if you drink it too fast you get
brain freeze
or it's like pepper if it's evenly
distributed in your food and you're
eating it slowly you're getting a little
bit at once it's really nice
but if you eat a giant lump all at once
it's not great
i am really into analogies today so the
skin equivalent of this
is irritation the other thing that can
happen is again with the microbes if you
have a product that wasn't designed to
go into your skin
maybe the preservative system wasn't
designed to be quite as good
you could be introducing microbes deeper
into your skin leading to an infection
so these are some of the mistakes i've
been seeing around have you done any of
these
i've definitely done a few are there any
mistakes that i've missed let me know in
the comments
if you like this video click the thumbs
up and the subscribe you can also check
out my blog and follow me on instagram
as well see you next time for more
beauty science